And so we reach the end of our journey through the architecture of despair.
You have now completed Miserable, How to Fail at Life, a comprehensive guide to optimizing
your existence for maximum suffering.
If you've made it this far, congratulations, you are now fully equipped to sabotage your
own happiness with precision and consistency.
Remember, true mastery is not the absence of failure, but the deliberate curation of
it.
A final note from The Reverse Maven.
This book is, of course, satire.
If any of these techniques actually resonated with you, if you found yourself nodding along
and thinking, yes, this is exactly what I do, then perhaps it's time to put down the audiobook
and pick up the phone, call a friend, talk to a therapist, go outside and look at a tree.
The self-help industrial complex is absurd, but genuine human connection, professional
mental health support and basic self-care are not.
This has been Miserable, How to Fail at Life, written and narrated by The Reverse Maven.
Production credits, audiobook generated using Chatterbox Turbo TTS with text preprocessing
by Alima Ministral.
Copyright 2025, all rights reserved.
Thank you for listening.
Now go forth, and be slightly less miserable.
End of audiobook.